Even the worst person can occasionally do a
good thing. In the movies, it happens with
some regularity. Keep watching for some bad guys
who redeemed themselves. A little, at least.
Few MCU characters undergo such radical
evolution as Thor's half-brother Loki,
and many fans would agree that Loki switched
from supervillain to superhero a while ago.
But in 2013's "Thor: The Dark World," he's
still fresh from his mass murder in "Avengers."
If nothing else is proof that he's still got a
toe in the dark side, there's his aid to Kurse
during the Dark Elf assault on Asgard and his
subjugation of Odin at the end of the film.
But we still see a more heroic side to the
trickster god in the Dark Elf world. When Thor
attempts to destroy the Aether with his lightning,
Loki rushes to shield Jane Foster from any harm.
Moments later, when Kurse lobs one of
the black hole grenades at the heroes,
Loki nearly sacrifices himself to
push Jane out of the way. Finally,
when Kurse proves too powerful for Thor to
handle alone, it's Loki's deceit that kills
the Dark Elf after he secretly attaches
a black hole grenade to the monster.
In 1983's "Return of the Jedi," Luke Skywalker
rejects the repeated advice of Yoda and Obi-wan,
who insist there is no salvation possible for
Darth Vader. Luke willingly surrenders himself
to Imperial forces, believing Anakin
Skywalker is still alive within Vader.
Vader brings Luke to Palpatine, and
ultimately, Luke must once more duel
his father, but this time, his victory
nearly pushes him to the dark side.
In the end, Luke's faith in his father is
redeemed. As Palpatine tortures Luke with force
lightning, Vader looks back and forth between his
son and the emperor, eventually choosing what no
one expects but everyone prays for. Rather than
let his son die, he lifts Palpatine from the floor
and — battered by the emperor's lightning —
hurls his former master down a long shaft.
In the end, Anakin not only saves
his son but proves he really is the
Chosen One the late Qui-Gon Jinn
knew he was so many years ago.
In 2004's "Spider Man 2," Otto Octavius, aka
Doc Ock, proves to be a much more sympathetic
villain than his predecessor Green Goblin.
After the robotic arms he initially uses
only to aid him in his scientific pursuits are
fused to his body, we learn the arms possess a
malevolent intelligence which begins influencing
everything Octavius does. Octavius is transformed
into an obsessed monster who will do anything,
including kill, to realize his scientific goals.
Thankfully, by the end of the film, Octavius
is able to emerge from the arms' influence and
redeem himself. In the climax, Octavius'
experimental fusion reactor is going wild
and endangering not only Spider-Man
and Mary Jane but the entire city.
Finally able to assert his dominance
over the robot arms, Octavius uses
them to save New York by plunging the reactor
into the East River. The last we see of him,
Octavius' seemingly lifeless body follows
the reactor toward the bottom of the river.
"I will not die a monster."
Long before they introduced us to The Dude of "The
Big Lebowski," Joel and Ethan Coen gave audiences
the 1990 gangster film "Miller's Crossing."
Gabriel Byrne stars as Tom Reagan, a high-ranking
adviser in the Irish mob who goes rogue when his
boss starts getting edged out of business by his
Italian rival, the unpredictable Johnny Caspar.
Tom's risky gambit is a long con — confusing both
friend and foe alike so he can win Caspar's
confidence and destroy him from the inside.
Through sheer relentlessness, one person
is able to sniff out Tom's game — Caspar's
brutal right-hand man Eddie Dane, aka the Dane.
Toward the end of the film, Tom is summoned to
Caspar's home, where the Dane waits to kill him.
At first, Caspar goes along with the Dane's plans,
doing nothing as he chokes the life out
of Tom. But just as Tom begins to fade,
Caspar crushes the Dane's nose with a
fireplace shovel, saving Tom and yelling
that it was the Dane who double-crossed
him. Minutes later, Caspar says to Tom,
"Look at this, kid. Something
I try to teach all my boys!"
He strides over to his desk, gets a
gun, and shoots The Dane in the head.
"Always put one in the brain."
For much of 2017's "Thor:
Ragnarok," Skurge isn't particularly impressive.
Not only is he the only warrior at the Bifrost
who doesn't lift a hand to stop Hela when she
arrives in Asgard, but even after he becomes her
so-called executioner, he pretty much just fields
Hela's evil monologues and lets the army of the
dead and Fenris do all the heavy lifting. In the
final battle, rather than commit to either side,
Skurge disguises himself and boards
the refugee ship, hoping to escape.
However, after Hela summons one of her spikes to
stop the refugee ship and her undead minions begin
pouring into the vessel, Skurge finally finds
his courage. He unveils his beloved rifles — Dess
and Troy — and mows down the unliving soldiers
before they can overtake the ship. Sacrificing
his own escape for that of his brethren, Skurge
leaps from the ship and fights off the army of
the dead as the ship pulls away. Like his comic
book counterpart's heroic last stand in 1985's
"Thor" #362, Skurge ultimately dies for Asgard, as
Hela kills him once she sees he's switched sides.
One of the most memorable scenes
in 1993's "Jurassic Park" is the
unveiling of the gargantuan T-Rex.
After escaping her enclosure,
she takes one of the first human victims of the
film when she devours the lawyer on the toilet.
She comes close to killing Hammond's grandkids
when she nudges their car off a ledge and
injures the chaos theorist Ian Malcolm enough to
keep him on his back for the rest of the film.
But in the end, it's the T-Rex who proves to be
the heroes' salvation. In the film's final act,
Hammond's grandchildren are hunted by the deadly
velociraptors in the visitor's center. Ellie and
Grant do their best to help the children, but
eventually, all four of them are trapped by two
of the hungry beasts in the center's main room.
Just as one of the raptors is about to strike,
the T-Rex reappears, snatches it off the floor
with its jaws, kills it, and begins eating it.
As the second raptor attacks the T-Rex,
the heroes take the opportunity to escape.
In the 1988 action comedy "Midnight
Run," everybody wants to capture the
fugitive accountant Jonathan Mardukas.
The luckless bounty hunter Jack Walsh
has Mardukas in custody for most of the
film, but they're pursued by the FBI's
Special Agent Alonzo Mosely, the mob,
and rival bounty hunter Marvin Dorfler.
In Texas, Walsh and Mardukas are cornered by two
mob goons. The heroes find an unlikely savior in
the form of the brutal Marvin Dorfler, who
knocks both goons out with the butt of his
shotgun. Walsh has no intention of giving his
bounty up to Dorfler, so he handcuffs himself
to Mardukas and seemingly throws away the
key. Dorfler loads them both into his car,
and they soon find themselves pursued by a
helicopter with a gangster sharpshooter on board.
Eventually things get desperate enough that
Walsh convinces Dorfler to give him a gun,
and the former takes out the chopper
with a shot to the tail rotor.
As Dorfler celebrates their salvation, Walsh
sucker-punches him, knocking him unconscious.
Dissimilar to the Marvel Comics, it’s rare
that X-Men's old enemy Magneto would ally
himself with his rivals or ever join their
team. The first time something like this
happens in the film adaptations, however,
is in the aptly named "X2: X-Men United."
After a confrontation with the Boston police
turns violent outside Bobby Drake's home,
the X-Men's Blackbird is pursued by a pair of
fighter jets. By dialing her powers up to 11,
Storm is able to get both pilots to eject but
not before one of them fires off two missiles.
Jean takes out one of the missiles
with her telekinesis, but the second
detonates close enough to the Blackbird
to send it spinning to the ground below.
As the jet drops, it inexplicably slows and
finally comes to a halt mere feet from the ground.
From outside the jet, we see Mystique and Magneto,
with the latter extending his arm and using
his powers to keep the jet from crashing.
As the X-Men begin to realize what's
happened, Magneto jokes to Mystique,
"When will these people learn how to fly?"
In the 1993 romantic crime drama "True
Romance," things change in a big way
for comic book store clerk Clarence and former
sex worker Alabama. This is when a combination
of vigilante justice and dumb luck deposits a
suitcase full of uncut cocaine in their laps.
They manage to get wealthy movie producer
Lee Donowitz to take the drugs off their
hands for a hefty sum, and the deal takes
place in an expensive LA hotel suite.
Unbeknownst to anyone else in the suite,
Donowitz's assistant Elliot is working
as an informant for the LAPD. Once the
deal is finalized, the cops charge in,
but Donowitz's private security guards
refuse to stand down. The standoff
gets more complicated when the mobsters who
want their drugs back burst into the suite.
Surprisingly, the standoff turns violent because
of the unarmed Donowitz. The producer goes wild
when he realizes Elliot betrayed him and throws a
tray full of hot coffee in his assistant's face.
Detective Nicholson opens fire in response, and
soon everyone is shooting. Elliot, Donowitz,
all of Donowitz's security, all the cops,
and almost all of the mobsters quickly die.
One of the gangsters makes
it as far as the hotel lobby,
where he's gunned down by uniformed
police. The only survivors are Clarence,
Alabama, and their friend Dick, though
Clarence loses an eye in the exchange.
Who would’ve thought that a deadly three-way
shoutout would become their saving grace?
In 2001's "The Lord of the Rings: The
Fellowship of the Ring," during the
heroes' trip through Moria, Gandalf had some
wise words for Frodo. He tells him that he
should have pity on Gollum's, as Bilbo did
when he spared Gollum’s life years prior.
Gandalf believes Gollum has a part
to play in there story still, saying,
"The pity of Bilbo may rule the fate of many."
The words prove prophetic more than once.
First, in spite of Gollum's inevitable betrayal,
Frodo and Sam would never have
made it to Mordor without him.
Second, in "The Two Towers" it's Gollum
who rescues Frodo when the hobbit is
mesmerized by the ghostly lights of
the Dead Marshes and nearly drowns.
Finally, there's the destruction of the One
Ring. When he finally makes it to Mount Doom,
like the human Isildur before him, Frodo is
overcome by the ring and decides to keep it.
He puts it on, immediately drawing the attention
of Sauron [SOW-ron] and his wraiths. It's only
because of Gollum's timely intervention —
chomping Frodo's finger off — that Sauron
is defeated. In the struggle that follows,
both Frodo and Gollum fall over the edge.
While Sam saves Frodo, Gollum descends into the
lava below, dying and taking the ring with him.
It may have not been Gollum’s virtuous intention,
but his lust for the ring
became the salvation for many.
His accidental sacrifice not only saved Frodo from
the ring’s power, but also the rest of the world.
The replicant Roy does some
terrible things in the 1982
sci-fi classic "Blade Runner," but in the
film's climax he chooses to save the life
of Deckard. Despite the fact that he’s
the hero who is not only hunting him but
has already killed two of the three replicants
who worked with Roy, including his lover Pris.
After Pris' death, Roy pursues Deckard through
the Bradbury Building, knowing he only has
minutes to live and presumably resolving to take
Deckard with him. Deckard manages to escape the
building to the rooftops but loses his gun in the
process. Unarmed and facing the super-strong Roy,
Deckard has no choice but to flee across the
rooftops, but he's no Spider-Man. His jump is
short on his way from one roof to the other, and
he begins slipping from the opposite ledge. Rather
than letting him fall, Roy easily leaps to the
ledge, waits until Deckard finally loses his grip,
and grabs the Blade Runner's wrist. With one hand,
Roy lifts Deckard and deposits him to safety.
In his final moments, Roy tells Deckard about
some of the amazing things he's seen in space,
regretting that those moments will be
lost in time, like tears in the rain.
Considering his words, it seems likely
Roy chooses to save his opponent not
out of forgiveness or any sudden surge
of moral righteousness. Rather, because
as a man seconds from death, he values life —
even that of an enemy — more than vengeance.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movie bad guys are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.